foreign
[Music]
marketing and I will be your host today
as cell engine therapy has quickly
merged as one of most transformative
Innovations in biofilm Industry
transcript offers a series solutions to
MicroCell engine therapy research easy I
see well here today the One Stop
solution for cell therapy workflow will
be introduced that enable researchers to
scale their operations with accuracy and
efficiency
the development mechanism and
applications of crisperging editing will
also be briefly introduced in today's
webinar you will hear from two
presenters Dr youngshin the director of
Rd development for protein products here
with genescript
Dr ifang Yu the project manager of Dell
therapy products with that I will turn
over to Dr Yvonne to begin today's
presentation
my name is Ethan Yu the project manager
of the third therapy products from
genescript today I will briefly
introduce the current situation of the
keto materials of cell therapy and also
share the information of the newly
launched cell isolation platform or
cytosync technology
so in today's talk we will share a
picture of the cell therapy first then
talk about the support from genescript
for the cell therapy process
and how we are improving or optimizing
the process lastly we will take a look
at their blooming allergenic Cell
Therapy market and share some insights
about their unmanned needs after raging
the instruments under the host solution
in this field
before talking about their current cell
therapy Market I would like to give a
quick review of what is car key
so the reasons people choose carti to
treat the cancer is that the engineered
T cells can better recognize their
cancer cells and kill them because of
their gvhd and the hvgd this therapy was
firstly developed from the atlagus
mainly because of their safety concern
so basically we are we can collect the
pbmcs from the patient itself then
perform the TCL isolation by using CD4
and cdaps they're using CD3 and cd20a
TCL activation based to stimulate T
cells which can help those cells can
have a better transfection successful
rates and the higher kidney efficiency
and after the activation now they would
wait for 24 to 48 hours before the gene
editing by using the antivirus to
transfect the card into the T cell
the slowly expansion for 10 to 14 days
until you have enough number of cells
lastly you can formulate the sample and
inject back to the patient itself
so the security of the Cartier therapy
is this point of care treatment can have
a extremely high CR and or comparing to
the traditional drugs and also since
you're using your own cells to treat
yourself the safety concern can be also
neglected
so I think everyone here probably have
seen this picture for more than valence
times so first patient with leukemia who
treated by the car key in 2010 ever
since then the cell therapy starts to
enter into a new era with the help of
their top immunologist and of course the
local authorities
and nothing is better than singer kid
who suffered from the leukemia now girls
a young healthy teenager because of car
T and now we have been believed that the
cell therapy is and will be one of the
best cure for all kinds of cancer
there are more than 2 000 cellotherapy
clinical trials all over the world and
over 500 therapy companies with their
own clinical Pipelines
there are seven criteria therapy which
has which has been commercialized
including the celticia from Legend
biotech one of our subsidiary companies
however due to the price of the quality
therapy is absolutely beyond the reach
almost a half million US dollars per
treatment the sales performance will I
can only say is not as good as expected
the total sales revenue of carti
products in 2021 is only 1.79 billion US
Dollars which is much lower than other
hot products like pd1 BDK or ADC and
besides we know as other CLP companies
start to start their own
commercialization of the products the
competition were becoming more and more
fierce
but to make sure their own products come
up from other Cartier products effexy is
one thing another thing is definitely
how to control the cost
so let's take a look at the listing
price of this commercialized security
products first so even the governments
from different countries figured their
way out by providing the patient
installation plan
still most of the patients cannot afford
it meanwhile from the figure here on the
right it is clear that the material cost
of what dose is almost reaching 80 000
US Dollars now mentioned about extremely
high labor cost
but we have to admit that there isn't
too much profit for the cell therapy
companies
solve this issue lowering the cost of
quality manufacturing is the only way
out one of the best way is to scale up I
mean to convert the car T from the
analogous to allergenic
among the car key production we can see
for each step they are likely they are
like multiple suppliers
however for the cell isolation reagent
more specifically clinical use cell
isolation beats there's only one
supplier
we know they're like currently Cell
Therapy companies for sale isolation be
supplier
there's only one
I mean regarding to their GMP
manufacturing process it is not entirely
compliant since there must be a backup
supplier now mention that the lung and
uncertain delivery time of those
clinical use isolation bits to average
two to three mouses delivery time
meanwhile the shelf life of the products
are only three to six months
the top right figure includes the
derivative time of some products we
bought from this single supplier not
only us many of our customers
complaining about that after they
receive the bids there isn't much time
left for them to use it
so from the last slide we can find out
that there are still so many issues and
unmanned needs from the cartoon
manufacturer regard including high cost
long delivery time limited options of
suppliers so here please allow me to
share some news from Earth's genescript
so our support for the cell therapy
process
that it is listed here so among the
whole therapy process we first focused
on the magnetic base technology they
expanded into cell isolation bits GCL
activation religion cell isolation
instrument and other products our goal
is to help the cellotherapy company to
lower their manufacturing cost and
increase their profitable space
so regarding to this part we can provide
a wetstop solution from the isolation
ranging columns tubing set and to the
automatic and cell isolation instruments
so the technology of the isolation bits
have been come out coming out almost for
several decades but while they're only
few supplies especially the GMP grid
non-resistant one there's only one now
including Earth
here I I would I will give some ideas
from the company level
why Earth's genescript can develop this
technology
to save isolation bits are consisted of
their magnetic core and the antibody to
develop the Beats which had which have
the outstanding isolation performance it
requires both good quality beats and the
suitable antibody
and genescript has 10 years experiences
in developing magnetic B product and we
have our track record in this field
along these 10 years we gathered very
experienced scientists from multiple
field including physics chemical
engineering and chemistry mean knowledge
molecular biology and so on
now mention that we have the building
GMP facility to acquire the most
regulated GMP products
meanwhile our antibody is provided by
one of the genescript substitute
companies change group profile where
they have a powerful and professional
antibody Discovery platform
through multiple clone selection and
thousands of process optimization and
conditioned screening we can use the
most suitable antibody for obese
and after we have the most suitable
antibody and best quality of bees our
final products were all valid validated
by a legend biotech to make sure the
best isolation performance of our Beats
I'm pretty sure not every company have
can have all these three platforms
so more specifically let's have a closer
look on our cell isolation bits right
figure is the structure of our cell
isolation and activation beats the size
of our base is around 100 nanometers and
the whole Matrix is not only non-toxic
and biodegradable
and left figure is the specs and the
features of our beads we can find out
that our isolation bits can achieve a
very nice isolation performance
regarding to the Purity and yield and
also this also comparable with our
competitors products
meanwhile our activation be sure better
expansion rate and higher on
differentiated amounts than using the
similar similar products from our
competitor
safety here means that regarding the
certain amount of the talking series the
absolute number of particle of the iron
content for using our bits is less than
using computers products due to the size
of our beats it doesn't need another
step of removal after the isolation
which is saved a lot of a huge amount of
time and process control
so picture here we summarize the overall
offerings from genes group for the
isolation we have the isolation based
targeting different subtype of subtype
of T cells and also the NK cells and
stem cells also the closed system tubing
set and cell isolation instruments
cytosync 1000 can be supported for the
cartoon Manufacturing
and here is the representative
application data for the CD4 and CDA
isolation a side-by-side comparison of
cell isolation beasts tubing set and the
instrument between ours and the
competitors is shown here
we can observe that our isolation
solution can provide a comparable
isolation performance regarding to the
impurity recovery and the cell viability
besides our instrument can provide a
customized process based on our
customers need for example if you need a
higher Purity or recovery we can work
with you to to realize this point by
adjusting the software not all in all
our cradle is what you need is what we
perceive
except for the isolation ranging C4 and
CDA beats we would also like to
introduce one of our Blockbuster
products the ncid T Cell Activation
reagent so for the expansion reagent a
better way to show it is definitely buy
for change because that is more relevant
to the downstream application
so here we choose three different donors
include including two pbmc and one local
pack
top three figures other phenotypes for
these three donors after the isolation
and the bottom pictures are the
corresponding expansion Force results
red line is the activation results using
our beats and blue line is from using
computer speeds so here we can find out
that our bees have an even higher
activation efficiency than our
competitor which is consistent with the
activation signal cd25 and
6669 results
we also would like to shoot the Monroe
Memorial phenotype so for the memorial
phenotypes of T cells we all know that
the T cells matures from Teen naive to
memory stem and T cells to Central
membrane T and to effector memory T
cells normally the less mature of this T
cells are more suitable for the
downstream application regarding to
their uh to the car transfection or
successful read and achilles efficiency
thus from the data here the amount of
the tscm and TCM after the activation
using our bits is comparable or higher
than using computers bits which means
using our activation reagent can have a
better can have a better benefits for
the downstream application in a car team
Manufacturing
from the last couple slides we can
observe that our activation Visa better
than the current products on the market
uh regarding to the cell expansion force
and Memorial phenotype
actually we will ask so many times that
is there any disadvantage for expanding
so fast or are those genescript bees
activate T cells more exhausted than
using comp using a competitors product
the left figure here show the exhaustion
marker lag 3 team 3 and pd1 were
monitored after activation for 14 days
there's no difference of the expression
of those exhaustion marker between using
our base and the the current products on
the market and also the red figure the
proliferation data if you focus on the
expansion rate from day 15 to day 17. it
is obvious that the active activated T
cells using our bits uh proliferate much
faster than using the other products and
this results indicates that the activity
teasers by our bits are more active
after activation than using the other
product
so besides the pro the products which
were commonly used in the autologous
karate genescript can also provide some
products which targeting the allergy
neck Cell Therapy Market
before that I would like to share some
of our ideas about this field regarding
to the key role materials and the
instrument
so we all know that the advantage of the
allergenic cell therapy is an affordable
price and the short delivery type due to
the of the Shelf properties
however there are still many challenges
I think thanks to the this top
scientists we already know how to
conquer overcome their gbhd for the Arlo
by performing the TCR Alpha Beta
depletion or using another type of sales
like NK sales
however there is no clear answer for the
challenge of the larger sample size
regarding to the devices or instrument
for each step such as isolation
expansion other final finish and Theory
so here we're going to talk about your
uh talk a little bit about uh the Raging
TCR Alpha Beta bits you know one of the
challenges of the alligenetic cell
therapy is how to come overcome the gbhd
I just mentioned and the scientists have
discovered that this can be solved by
performing the TCR of beta depletion
using the beads
so in the current market
um only address one uh there's only one
GMP grid TCR Alpha Beta kit
however this kit can have a contest two
valves of antibiotin beads and one vial
of bouting Lady TC Alpha Beta antibody
and this is so called the indirect
labeling cell isolation method or the
two-step method which means you have to
incubate anybody first with the cell
sample then do the centrifuge to wash
and remove the free antibody some extent
then add the base to perform the
incubation again
and this two-step isolation is very time
consuming tedious and when comparing to
the one step isolation
and this one step isolation can be
exactly provided by the GCR for beta
bits from genescript
and our TCR for beta is pictured on the
bottom panel which can be directly
incubated with the cell sample so you
can imagine this will be more time
saving easy to scale up and also can
give you a better set of stairs after
the isolation because one step can
minimize the cell injury at a great
extent
so regarding to the application uh the
application of our TCR for beta base it
can be used both as depletion and
enrichment and figure a here is the
effects data for the depletion one
million pbmcs were started with the
depletion using a chain Square TCR for
beta bits and after the depletion the
purity of the TCR for Alpha Beta
negative sales was discovered described
in the figure B which shows we have the
comparable results with the computers
TCR for beta depletion kits
except for Raging we already
used our way to perfect this
imperfection
from
O2 to Arlo the sample size before the
isolation will be 100 to 1000 times
bigger normally for the R2 total sales
of the starting sample will be around a
10 to a nice level this level but for
the aloe the total sales before the GC
Alpha Beta depletion is Run 10 to 11 or
even 10 to 12.
we know the current isolation instrument
can only precise the amount of the sales
for R2 so there's no insurance there's
no instrument or this only limited
Solutions in a current market for the
other genetic cell therapy
and even though uh authorities highly
suggest do not split the samples into
many instruments
this is the only way out I don't see our
therapy companies have to split the
sample and use multiple cell isolation
instruments
and now Mission the extremely long
isolation time which which would cause
the cell injury and the low viability
so fortunately you have genescript we
are about to launch our second
generation's isolation instrument silos
into 2000 which is developed for the
design for the allergenic markets
the multi-channel design can make sure
it has a high throughput which made the
needs for the other Market
foreign
it has the ability to help help to
increase the isolation efficiency by
decreasing the isolation time which can
enhance their cell status and the fully
closed and audit tracking system that
can be used for cellotherapy
manufacturing process
so all right here is the overall picture
of our silosync GMP grade products our
building GMP facility can guarantee the
quality of our GMP products in a great
extent which can support the cell
therapy companies for their r d or ble
applications and meanwhile we can
provide a smaller size of GMP grade CD4
and cdaps which can help the cell
therapy company save more their
manufacturing costs because we we know
most of people won't use the whole 7.5
mil for for one local pack
So currently we have both an Ru grid and
GMP grid isolation activation magnetic
uh beats and also the compatible manual
separation System including the magnetic
reacts different size of the magnet and
columns now most importantly we not only
can provide the automatic cell isolation
instrument
1000 also the first of its kind
specially designed for allergenic Market
the Next Generation high throughput
multi-channel it's the isolation
instrument cytosync 2000 besides on 2023
next year we are planning to launch a
much more products including cell
isolation bits against other targets and
some solutions for the for other steps
in the car key so here is a email of our
company please don't hesitate to contact
us if you have any questions or need
some talkies for tests
all right
um thank you thank you a lot for your
time and attention lastly I would like
to mention that most most of our
products have been tested by multiple
external customers uh those who are
leading Cell Therapy companies or the
academic Institute and so far all the
beta tests testing feedbacks are very
positive so please feel free to ask me
any questions you want thank you
that's the events were the informatic
presentation about cell therapy in this
section we will talk about Gene editing
which is the state of art approach that
normally works together with cell
therapy with you today my name ishan I'm
the director of r d department for
protein products at genescript
especially I will talk about how to
optimize the gene editing efficiency in
RMB mediated crispr test in cells
discussion has three major parts
begin with the introduction of crispr
cas9 system and then talk with about the
optimization of the gene editing
experiment and finally we give you the
genescript solution
now let's start the discussion about the
basic introduction of this forecast line
system
cell therapy is now the superstar in
family here we demonstrated a simplified
procedure for generating currently cells
isolating T cells from pbmc are first
activated an engine additive with
multiple methods among which crispr cas9
is now become trending so what is the
crystal
is shown for classical regularly
displays shortened and then dramatic
repeat
the crisper cast is a microbial adaptive
immune system finding passages this RNA
guiding nucleus to cleave foreign
genetic elements six types of crispr
systems have been identified in various
types of microbes and among which the
type 2 is one of the best characters
in nature this tester system is composed
of two key components a crystal
Associated new type and guide RNA
consisting crrna and Tracer RNA complex
the gene editing vipers broadcast my
other life is an official single-cloud
RNA at TRNA which is a fusion of CRNA
and Tracer RNA
with the wash and click base pairing
test line is guided to the Target DNA by
the IC RNA and the only introduce EMA
double stranded bread PSPs to the locus
adjacent of the Proto spacer adjacent
Motif pan we creative critical
components of Tesla are pen interaction
domain
hnh nucleus domain and a react nucleus
domain the pi domain binds to its
recognized
site upon stream the pen sequence and
then dsps of the target DNA performed by
the other two
the H and H
cleave is the target strength while the
rack
brings the non-target string
from the mechanism it is quite clear
that the specific cleavage is achieved
by the base pairing between Target DNA
and sgrna as well as The Binding of M
and the pi domain this broadcast line
system generates double strength Break
On Target Gene and generally it can be
prepared by two pathways
the non-homologist and join password and
the homology directed The repair
password
nhej gives rise to small angles and a
result in loss of function mutation
within the target Gene which is the
mechanism of Gene knockout application
HDR can generate specific nucleotide
change ranging from a single nucleotide
change to large incitations and
scientists utilize this pathway for
working in design routine to target
cells meanwhile a DNA replied A repair
template pain in the denied sequence
must be delivered into the cell type of
Interest with the grna and cas9
I demonstrated in the picture all right
generally there are three ways to
deliver quiz broadcasting system in 2000
n a RNA and rmp the rmp is a composition
of cast iron nucleus and irony
sharing with other two methods the rnp
delivery is in positive due to the
benefits of higher education efficiency
amendment of targeted rates low toxicity
as it is not using virus there is no
risk on Gene integration and also it is
DNA free and it is also the quickest way
of editing
in this however the bottleneck of the
rmp form is the limited Deliverance
visibility due to the high molecular
mass of complex
currently
electroporation is one of the most
popular methods for rmp delivery for
Gene editing experiment in this talk we
will focus on the use of electric
operation methods delivered rmp into
cells for Gene editing
with this
now we go to section two to discuss how
to optimize the gene editing experiment
this is a workflow of first broadcast
line knockout experiment to walk through
the whole process step by step
as described in Section 1 S9 nuclear and
sgrna are the most important components
please forecast night system forming an
rnp tongue tactical image at Target
genes thus for successful crispr
experiment it is essential and necessary
to utilize a proper cas9 nuclear and
design an Optimum sgr name with high
activity and specificity Additionally
the optimization of rmp is also
essential to improve the gene editing
performance
first let's start with the selection of
cas9 nucleus
and it has my
a lot for special purpose
for example one hypothesis is that by
neutralization of positive charge
derivatives of targeted growth The
Binding between non-target DNA and sgrna
can be greatly worked thereby function
developed the airspeak hazard the
highest result
on the other hand idea assisted
continuous Evolution and developed the
svcast9 mutant with a propane
compatibility as well as a higher DNA
sentence or X has not many other methods
are developed including looking for past
night proteins from other spaceship such
as dbo cas9 was found from East with so
many cas9 for use when it comes to the
selection of Cathay protein multiple
criteria needs to be considered such as
the basic activities the surfacity pen
selection and size of protein first
thing first one should know his purpose
clearly and the choice accordingly here
we have an interesting paperwork to
share in this paper authors developed a
method to comprehensively prepared
activity and responsibility of cas9
protein mutants
according to their results
it seem that there is a train that most
of modified calcite nucleus which
enhance the specificity generally showed
a decreased cleavage activity
this reason is made related with the DNA
RNA complex which we will not cut in
deep here but clearly based on a
phenomenon which one should select a
suitable cast like nucleus based on
pieces purpose especially it is
suggested to choose the class 9 was
increase the specificity for those
applications that require low of
calculated
here we are showing the experiments of
testing various cases and figure one
different sources of cas9
shows significant differences On Target
efficiency use the same screen sgr name
and figure 2 different source of Castile
nucleuses show significant difference in
of targeted efficiency by maintaining
the same similar On Target efficiency
within screening sgiano
from those figures and see different
mutants of Catholic nucleus from
distinguishly and both On Target and
off-target effects which remind us again
that selecting a proper class 9 nucleus
is very important and it requires
experimental screening for specific
purposes
now it comes to the sgrna part
as we mentioned before in nature that
RNA is a CRNA Tracer RNA complex
Dr RNA has 20 NT guys sequence which
directs the cas9 to a 20 MP DNA Target
the sgr name is the Chimera of crrna and
the Tracer RNA complex encoded with 20
NT Target sequence highlighted in Orange
here which is the most important part
for the precise Gene engine the rest
sequence of sgrnas doogenous functions
and is quite important before binding to
sgrna and cas90 code and it is
consistent for a specific cas9 nuclear
source overall the specificity of crispr
AC is determined by the base pairing
between sgrna and Target DNA and the pen
sequence recognized by castline nucleus
thus for different Target addition with
the selected casting nuclei is only
required to change the target sequence
present in grna but how to design a
well-performed sgra for a specific
crispr test
first the design of sgrna depends on
your specific experiment further
considerations of Gene sequence targeted
by the sgrna there are some basic rules
for Gene knockout and knocking
for knocking we need to select the sgrna
targeted position and function related
axles in gene of Interest
you need to avoid Target's position
being too close to N or C terminal of
Geo I
for knocking you need to select the gene
insertion position on Gmail and it
should be around plus minus 30 NT
when it is not able to find appropriate
insertion position that can GG Pam
sequence for sdk9 you will need to use
either cast proteins with different pen
such as cast 12-way there are many
online tools to help with the sgr and
dni well the operator only need to input
The Selective Target sequence from Gene
of interest and online tools will output
without boost scores based on many
behind principles setting tools such as
the GC content the lens of Target
sequence is patch matching consideration
as well as the pen sequence
here we list the commonly used online
sgrni design tools such as chop chop it
contains it covers genes from various
species
such as human mice rats and they also
bee can be used for multiple cast
proteins such as cas9 plus 12 8.
the design sgrna must be validated
experimentally to evaluate the
performances
here we have an interesting
demonstration
first the picture we have the data for
knockout in Joker cells clearly
different sgrna should break the
differences about efficiency
don't we pick up two sgrna which have
identical efficiency in Reverse
experiment through the primary T cells
with the same Target the results show
Dramatical differences this time
indicating both the sgrna and the
working cell type affect the final Gene
editing results
thus for Save generally we recommended
to design five to six sgrna for further
screening and the validation
with the selected SG cas9 and sgrna we
can assemble the rnp complex
so first we need to consider the more
ratio between these two the first figure
showed that with different ratios The
Knockout efficiency varied greatly with
the fixed rnp amount
and um the total amount for an rmp
complex also matters here we have an
example showing to fix the mole ratio by
increasing the rmp amount you can
achieve greatly improved knockout
efficiency
we have talked about the basics for rmp
from cas9 nucleus sgrna to the
construction of rmp itself multiple
criteria have been mentioned separately
which part but when it comes to the real
experimental design one should think
comprehensively to reach the best
results at the end
with the assemble the rmp complex we now
can deliver the rmp in two cells
for most cell-based Gene editing
experiments
electroporation is one of the most
popular delivery methods due to its high
delivery efficiency and simpler
operation it also of less 50 000
generally it is practical to refer to
suppliers per Toco for the operation of
electric operation
however it is also recommended to
optimize the Electoral operation
conditions for rmp transfection with the
consideration for cell types the
viability and cell numbers
normally the sale will be cultural the
work period after RMB transaction one
should determine the cultural period
here based on
specific applications generally the 48
hours or 22 hour data is analyzed for
primary T-cell Gene lockup exit
the result analysis for crispr
experiment can be found the DNA level
RNA level and protein level of each
level there are commonly used methods
especially on the DNA level we can
access the of Target efficiency this can
be done in June white analysis as well
as by evaluating the predict of Target's
Locus
37 U1 mismatch detection essay is widely
used for evaluating the activity of
Chris bucket determine it is simple but
not very accurate as it is not analyzing
The genome sequence direct flow the
Sounder and NGS sequencing are the most
popular methods for outlining The genome
sequence directly
which help us to understand further
about the basic effects of crispr
canceling system targeting Gene of
Interest
the qpcr and the RNA stack are the
methods for targeting the RNA detection
which help us understand the crisprene
editing at transcription level
first upload and effects are used for
evaluating the editing efficiency on a
protein Apple which directly show the
expression condition before and after
the gene editing experiment
with all the elements discussed we have
walked through the workflow step by step
and discuss the key points for each
in the last section we will give you the
genescript solution for a high Gene
editing efficiency
in team script we have major Cat 2 cast
9 Pro nucleus one is the widely used SP
constant word type and the other is the
Newton ESPN which was developed by phone
John group as mentioned before those two
proteins are divided in liquid from IO
to GMP satisfying your new different
levels
both cast iron in three different
they all have very high key or
efficiency here is an example
will knock out the Trac Target primary T
cells we achieve High 95 percent Gene
editing efficiency both proteins in
three different
they are very high activity and the
result is very consistent
especially for USB casting as we already
mentioned it hasn't enhanced the
specificity it will provide Trac
knockout income cells
using eye Garden method it is a clearly
show that
the off-target effect is much lower by
type yes SP cas9 and the Newton from
attitude
for different transaction scale our
nucleus performance center they will
demonstrate that without 20 microbes
100 micro leads system at the same time
and you can see clearly that they are
knocking out efficiency are very similar
to both two proteins and meanwhile we
actually are achieving higher self cell
viability in large scale transaction
the stability of genescript nucleus is
demonstrated here
it is clear that
under different stressed conditions our
proteins show very high probability
meaning that our code cas9 protein it
can be very stable for long-term storage
for commercial customers we have many
IND and boa support for you EMF of our
product has been received by FDA as well
as a document
the courts will accelerate your r d
process
our manufacturing facility is introduced
here showing our probability in
manufacturing GMP products for ancillary
materials
if you have interest in your product
in contact with
they give you selection guidance on
products here like listed in this table
as well the application recommendation
manufacturing condition details such as
the QC release standards who are you
open the GMB and GMP query of our
we can also give you the typical work
conditions of our nucleus to help you to
start with
with this I will have to end today's
discussion if you have any question
related please feel free to contact us
with this email address product dot tech
support at Jane squid.com
thank you for your time and attention
see you